this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to audit.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like pressing code Joey
and get 10 off delivered right to your
house what's happening you bad
[__] it's when Thursday the
third of [__] November a
beautiful day to be alive the joint is
brought to you by stamps.com listen it's
not too late to get your holiday mailing
and shipping under control with
stamps.com it's about to blow up you
don't want to be at a post office
standing online
for carrying your stuff sign up now and
you'll be printing your own postage a
minute how easy is stamps.com I'll tell
you tip top Magoo they got a scale you
get your package you put on the scale it
prints the postage you put it in your
mailbox put the little hanger up and the
mailman comes and get it use stamps.com
the prince postage whenever you do
business or you is a computer and a
printer with stamps.com you can easily
schedule pickup and compare carriers and
rates with the click of a button and if
you're running an online store stamp.com
Works seamlessly with all major shopping
carts and marketplaces so stop messing
around whether you got a small business
or a huge business the holiday season
trade late nights for silent nights and
get started with stamps.com today sign
up with promo code Joey j-o-e-y for a
special offer that includes a four-week
trial free postage and a digital scale
no long-term commitments or contracts
just go to stamps.com click on the
microphone at the top of the page and
enter code Joey the joint is also
brought to you by CBD lion the king
listen everybody's talking about CBD
stop it stops right here with CBD lion
how do I know I've been working with
them for four years they have taken care
of me with the cream the kinesiology
tape the bath balls they got oh my God
they got some CBD gummies that'll put
you another planet and never mind
they'll Delta eight so do yourself a
favor go to CBD line right now read the
alert the third party lab results and
make your decision when it comes to CBD
CBD line is the best click in Joe in the
Box joint or church and get 20 off your
first order now without further Ado I
got little Lee in studio let's get this
party started
foreign
[Music]
you bad [__] it's a beautiful
Wednesday here I'm Uncle Joey's joint my
main man is in studio today
we got a show tonight so far you know we
do it just getting ready last night we
got a little tuned up
uh lee a 40 milligrams liar you thought
he was a liar [__] 200.
40 milligrams yeah okay yeah and I'm
eight feet tall
and and I have a six pack oh my God he
was [__] up and so was I he got off on
one little mushroom thing for one little
yeah yeah okay one little one
milligram no there was multiple it was
one mushroom a lot of substances and it
was [__] Edibles 40 milligrams that's
it 40 milligrams
it's 40 milligrams I was not free I did
a good job I got 25 and 50s so they add
up to [__] 40 milligrams even that 75
no 25 to 25 is 50. the worst case
scenario you could ate was 25 [__]
milligrams last night worst case yeah 40
40. I'm sorry I'm getting all confused I
might be having a stroke 40 [__]
milligrams he ate last night uh I had to
wake him up 10 times during the [__]
thief I was getting into that movie yeah
that was a good one I've never seen it
it was it was crazy the coolest class I
ever took was a 1970s film class and I
could just tell by the intro to the
movie that it was from like you said it
was like 80 so it was like right on the
edge yeah they made that in 79 it came
out in 80. but that intro was just so
cool it was just it was long he didn't
say anything no he was like the [__]
say yeah it was a cool I wish I could
have finished it but it was my one of
Michael Mann's earlier movies
and he was [__] good then Michael man
like you know everybody's good in the
beginning when you then they Branch out
but Michael Mann was [__] good he did
that other movie mind hunter or
something that we covered and thief the
first time I saw a thief I thought I was
going to jump out a [__] window
because it answered all Mike well like
anything I had in my mind that mindset
he had right nothing means nothing and
[__] you know you expect these things
to happen and nothing happens just all
those things sucked me to [__]
I mean that's why I became a thief
because of that movie I loved it so much
she get we should that's why you became
a thief I swear to God Jesus Christ
drove me insane I got into alarms and
electronics and how to tap into alarms I
that's all I wanted to learn and then
when I went to Snowmass Village I bumped
into an electrician and he was teaching
me how to [__] do the alarms but
every time I did a real live on whatever
I would get caught wait the [__]
alarm would go off or something like
that so I just learned to break the
window and run it and take everything
yeah before the cops could get there
because I wasn't going to launch system
I can't I can't imagine you messing with
alarms you seem much more like kick grab
run nothing much more your style there's
an electrician and one of the reasons
why I became a residential Wireman
thinking back is because I'll get a
quick class and wiring and alarm systems
and [__] but it never [__] it never
[__] panned out you know it never
really pan well thank God
one time
and I and I actually took the like me
and my two buddies took the suction cup
and we're gonna cut the glass like with
the suction cup that's a real thing I
thought that was just in movies that's a
real thing you can get yeah you could do
it if you a specialized trained in it
you have to get the construction you
have to get the suction cup and then go
around and the suction cup pulls out the
glass we were there for like two hours
trying to clean the glass we just
punched the [__] glass of one and a
half to an hour let's sit out here and
[__] scrape the glass that's exposure
you know we had to Rob this guy in the
daytime because he worked I don't know
what his schedule was we used to have to
Rob white went to ShopRite or something
so Jesus but yeah that movie [__] put
me over when I was
my senior summer in high school HBO
wasn't like it was today okay HBO was
HBO that's it there was no HBO Latino no
HBO family no HBO exclusive none of this
[__] you know it was just HBO and HBO
didn't have in 1980 they didn't have 3
000 movies to pick from and then they
have 2000 series
they pretty much played the same movies
only in different orders okay but there
was a short time period in my life from
like October of 81 to like January of
82. that the thief the Raging Bull and
Hollywood Nights was on every night in
that order sometimes it would be Raging
Bull Hollywood Knights or the thief or
sometimes it would be so you're catching
every night at some point every night so
I would come home get my brother Mike
we'd walk down a Pathmark shoplift the
[__] out of that place with four bucks
in preparation for the thief you feel
like we gotta oh we got the Panthers
tomato soup and protein shakes with
[__] eggs wheat germ [__] eggs we
used to put everything in a protein
shake and drink it oh I didn't I didn't
steal it but I loved to go I love going
to the store before like I have a really
good movie I want to watch
oh yeah you just walk around like yeah
it looks good I love when I used to
[__] be younger I would get like
spreads of Chinese food like I would
just get pork fried rice two entrees
yeah and then every appetizer a [__]
dumpling a [__] egg roll
soup I love spare ribs taking on a stick
and I just sit there and watch three or
four movies in a day yeah like when
[__] in Snowmass Village when the
season ends
there's nothing to do April 15th that's
it it's over everybody goes home right
and all the whole city is melting that
whole move that whole [__] mountain
of snow right has to [__] melt so
there's nobody around
so I used to just work a video store
like at night from five to seven going
there to bring back movies for people to
rent movies it was my busiest time but I
swear to God I used to get up at eight
walk the dog
[__] eat breakfast and wait for the
Chinese restaurant to open yeah oh and
it was shitty Chinese food and I just
sit there and watch three four movies
eating a pack of egg roll egg roll smoke
a joint then you hit the ribs smoke a
joint take a [__] egg fried rut pork
fried rice even shitty Chinese food is a
is pretty good Chinese food no but
you're burping during the movie who
cares you're by yourself
a piece of moo goo got pans in your rib
I don't want to go through that either
oh yeah you're gonna have some it's
gonna be smelly but it's gonna be fun
last night you said something to my wife
at dinner oh boy Popeye's chicken or
something oh yeah and I wanted to tell
you the last time I went to Popeye's
Chicken was the one on our corner right
we had the one on Laurel Canyon right
yeah you never went there it was two
blocks from my house of course I went
there walked there backwards oh my god
oh you did they when that Ali was
surrounded he had he had [__] Jack in
the Box Popeyes you know what and I did
a bad boy someone taught me the fattest
move ever there's a papa if you know
it's Laurel Cannon and Magnolia there's
a Popeyes and across the street is a
wiener schnitzel slash Frosty Freeze now
the wiener schnitzel even as fat as I
was is disgusting disgusting Frosty
Freeze on the other hand is fantastic so
people it's literally
across a four-lane street so you'd go
out of the drive-through of Popeyes and
if you time to just right you go
immediately you wouldn't even take a
turn you would just go straight into
this Frosty Freeze you'd get a milkshake
and ice cream and I lived like it was
the fact that I drove there was crazy
okay it took more time to drive than it
would have taken a walk but there was no
way I was gonna walk and I would do oh
that double yeah no I'm not going in you
can't even go in that's how disgusting
wiener schnitzel is it's just a stand it
really is but it really is oh but yeah
the last time you went you were saying
what was the other place you said there
was one there was there was Jack in the
Box there was Taco Bell down the street
by by your block Jack in the Box was up
Laurel down right by that Starbucks
okay yeah yeah oh yeah that that was not
a good there was you were positioned
around oh that was fat heaven then there
was yum yums right down the street dude
I went to I did the math I think I spent
in my 10 years in La I think I spent 100
Grand on fast food probably eating
eating not just fast food but the
majority of it fast food I could tell
you every McDonald's Taco Bell Wendy's
within the valley within from
Sepulveda to Lankershim
I know most of them
wow because I know I know which ones are
open late because that was that one on
Burbank and Lincoln now not Burbank and
Lankershim uh Lankershim and the right
by the church Riverside Riverside
Lankershim that one's open late but
sometimes you'd catch a line there so
I'd go to other ones the one on Victory
is not bad I I that's the book that's
the book The Fat Man guide to Eaton oh
but it wasn't even like like the thing
that you said that and I hate that it's
right but it's like if you're gonna eat
save it for something good like it
towards the end of me being fat I'd go
to McDonald's and even I liked it but
half the time the fries are cold it's
not even good like going back to I was
just in La for a week and I think I had
Mexican food nine times in six days
and that that was worth it I gained like
seven pounds in the week and I didn't I
didn't care because I just ate
there that that's what you go to La for
not for like I I even had a plan to go
to Jack In The Box in my trip back I had
a plan because like I can't get that out
here
I didn't even I went to what would you
go in the Jack in the Box and probably
pick up dude when we were doing a
podcast and this is and this is how bad
it was my menu didn't really change but
we were doing the podcast at six in the
morning
for a while and I would go to Jack In
The Box after because you'd give me
Edibles and I wouldn't have to work till
night time so that was my dinner because
I'd come straight from work you get
you'd get and see the problem with Jack
in the Box is so my normal fast food is
either the one bird one big burger with
two chicken things or one chicken thing
with two like dollar menu Burgers the
problem with Jack in the Box is their
burgers and their chicken sandwiches
aren't
well you get a job when you're going to
Jack In The Box you're going for those
tacos it's those disgusting tacos
the foot the big one no well yeah yeah
like it's two for 99 cents it's that's
definitely horse or something
I'd get the the burgers but the burgers
my like my fat place was Wendy's Wendy's
was but and thank God it wasn't that
close
but the Wendy's was where I'd get
go ham I'd get towards the end I would
get a large fry and a small fry now how
long did you eat fast food for from you
being a kid or not really my mom
occasionally very occasionally
um I didn't start really getting fat
until I got my car because then I could
like go to lunch off school and then I
went to college in Boston so I was fat
but like I kept it under control because
I could eat when I first moved to LA and
I was working nights is just when it
[__] went it was my entire trash can
was just bags and cups because I just go
I'd go to fast food every day
it's I don't know Lee I just was never
really
like a big fan listen we all have
[__] [__] that we wrestle with I mean
last night we came home stoned we didn't
eat but I ate [__] 10 of my
daughter's Halloween candies you know
well I eat Halloween candies again
tonight not at all it's it's so weird
how my logic is like I'll eat it one
time and that's it I'll do I go to the
gym for four days before I slip up again
yeah I don't I can't I
people talk about like it being getting
easier it's still like we got my
favorite thing in this area I think you
call it shrimp beets it's like fried
shrimp with like red sauce on it and
that's all it is but if the shrimp is
great and the red sauce is great so we
got that but it had they put a nice
piece of fresh bread with just sauce
poured on top and the the fact that I
didn't eat it
like we like we bet down here you could
have I would have been against myself
because I I can't it's hard for me not
to eat stuff like if I see stuff like
that or if like I don't know like with
you with Mercy or Terry if they don't
finish something do you finish it no oh
I can't I can't it's
I will destroy it it's crazy how I was
never really listen we all eat some type
of junk nobody's [__] perfect okay
everybody eats some type of junk food
you pick up a cookie here and especially
when you have kids yeah you know and I
learned that the hard way this summer
because this summer
I was doing a lot more with the kids and
it I'm like oh I'm going to Jujitsu I
can get away with eating this no you
can't no no you can't and I was buying
like Italian ices yeah Italian ices are
100 calories Gino's the the no sugar
ones the 100 calories but that's great
until you look at the label and you're
like oh it really is 100 calories for a
spoon yeah there's eight servings and
something this much they don't [__] that
should be illegal I think that should be
illegal they're just trying to [__] with
fat people I was eating two Italian ices
that night Gina you know until one day I
looked at the box and I'm like what the
[__] am I doing with my life you know
it's not ice cream you you you you know
like I said we all can't be [__]
virgins you know if somebody maintains
that because they're fighting or
something that's great right but this is
life you're going to have uh you know
everyone has something that they deal
with I used to always say that to you
okay I'm gonna eat rice patties and tuna
okay you're gonna lose 200 pounds eating
that but how are you gonna sustain that
so that means you're gonna have to eat
that the rest of your life or how are we
gonna do this how we gonna [__] do
this so what does this mean when you
stop eating
rice cakes and tuna
what we're going to eat and by that time
you're going to bust and you're going to
maintain for a while and then you're
going to want to eat a cheeseburger I
mean we're all [__] Sinners when it
comes to that [__] fast food I don't
know Lee I just
listen
I think that the country I think that
the way it goes is when kids go to
college
because they're pension for money they
[__] eat
shittiest stuff
but and it's against you know it's like
smoking cigarettes you see somebody
smoking a cigarette today you're like
how the [__] are you smoking this
cigarette you know what the [__] after
all the propaganda that's out there and
all the [__] you're still smoking a
cigarette no matter what I think it was
laziness for me with the fast food
because I was just tired I was I was
working I would be like 12 hours between
driving there and driving back and I
just didn't it was just late it wasn't
good like I do like it but yeah it's
just saving time
but it also it gets addicting it's
[__] crazy what it does I like I like
our your friends just did uh sober
October
I do sober October other than wheat I
guess but drinking wise I could do this
over a year and I wouldn't even notice
it just has not even
the least I if we if we're going out and
I have a drink right I enjoy it but it's
not you could tell me that alcohol
disappeared and it wouldn't do [__] to
me
and there's people who love it and it's
just I got unlucky that mine is food I
guess
I got the same luckily because I don't
like [__] alcohol I can't even
imagine having a drink like if it's
between a drink and a spare rib a
Chinese not even close I'm not even you
know it fits again if it's a [__]
cocktail or a [__] Italian spare rib
from the feast oh I'm not I'm not
there's no question there you know so
that's always very easy for me but I was
I also have the the bad luck that I love
food man yeah I love listen I love
reefer and I love food and I'm not going
to sit here because while I'm talking to
you I'm thinking about my batches with
fast food
my back and Boulder there's no [__]
fast food I mean it's too nice Abo's
Pizza or something like that but I
didn't eat that [__] at all you know and
then I think when I got to
when I first started selling cars there
was a Jack In The Box up the corner and
again you're working 12 13 hour days
you're not gonna go home and make a
[__] bowl of chicken soup so you go
to Jack In The Box and I never ate the
burgers I used to eat the seafood salad
oh that's the seafood you never got sick
I would just get nervous at that point
my body couldn't get sick
I was living in high altitudes I was you
know I was athletic so my body I was
eating a seat but this is the clink I
was eating a lettuce tomato
salad right and they sprinkle like
artificial crab meat right they take
like lizard and spray paint and so you
think it's crab they spray paint they're
white and put like Indian red on the
side you know so we [__] eat it like
I went somewhere my wife brought home a
lobster bisque a couple weeks ago she
goes try it it was horrible and to add
insult to injury they put artificial
crab meat in it hello
Red Lobster Bisque why is that crab meat
in this [__] and not even real
crab at least put some Jersey iodine
crabs yeah so at least I could lose an
eye or say I ate some this is nothing
that was just artificial crab meat but
that was but I was also drinking and I
got no reason to lie I would also I was
also drinking the biggest [__] iced
tea they sold oh yeah this thing was a
bucket and I still remember pulling over
you know when you give you the driving
yeah pulling over in the Subaru and
pouring out like two inches on top
because I put
easy
I just bought a [__] pour or sugar
I used to just go to [__] was it
unsweetened iced tea or was it already
look at that unsweetened and that would
be I don't know 32 ounces the big one
you know after a while it gets old to
open up a sugar packets yeah yeah about
50 of them I would just sit there and
I'm not ready I would put so much like
with a box of sugar yeah I would just
pour it in and it would be like two
inches of sugar on the bottom and I just
Stir It Up I love the way I drank my
iced tea and you drink it you get the
sugar crystals you're like oh [__]
that's good yeah I used so one day I got
on the scale and I was 18 pounds heavier
yeah oh yeah I'm like 215 I'm like why
am I 215 I eat a salad every day duh
abdominal [__] sugar every three days
oh that's crazy I was buying a box like
the little you know not the big thing
with the leaks the box with the metal
and yeah I've been keeping the glove
compartment who does that I know people
bring hot sauce you know and you're like
what the [__] is wrong with you but I
had my own sugar for those things so and
right before I got sentenced yeah right
before I committed the crime I was
eating [__] Seafood salads every day
oh but that's that's a crazy place to
gain weight you just mentioned jail I
hear people sometimes gain a lot of
weight in jail because like they go to
like the store or whatever and get all
those cakes what you have is you and but
then again
this is Food For Thought too for all you
guys that want to buy protein powders
and think protein powders are [__]
gonna get you big look at those guys in
prison
when I was in prison I was in the best
shape of my life because my snacks were
sardines
okay I refuse to you know you could go
home and you went to the store for 20
minutes right they sell commissary okay
you know which is everything in the
world for you and they sell [__] uh
you know beef jerky popcorn Oscar Mayer
[__] salami none of that shit's good
for you
when I got when I was in the system
going to my destination sure I [__]
ate whatever they gave you plus you eat
starch
that's all you're eating is pasta rice
the meat ain't that real good by the
time you get to your destination you
already know and you talk to there's
people who don't give a [__] what they
eat and then there's a couple black
dudes that are in shape and they're like
don't eat that eat that get your protein
from that Source it's [__] Wild
but I was locked up with guys that were
yoked some of them did get steroids sent
in there but there was like 10 of them
that were yoked from being in there for
four years doing push-ups pull-ups
squats running that's what they did
Jesus and they had veins all over their
[__] bodies and they drank water and
you know I drank Kool-Aid when I was in
jail that's you know there's no soda
right but I'm not gonna drink water it's
bad enough you're in jail now I gotta
drink [__] water you know what I'm
saying room temperature tap water too
coming out of the toilet [__] you I want
my [__] Kool-Aid so it's kind of
weird it's uh there's people who do take
care of themselves in there you know
listen when we ate the nachos we use
government cheese
and we melted in a bucket with a [__]
iron
like you know the irons yeah take the
iron Rod out yeah and that's how they
melt that cheese that cheese can't be
any good for you no you're getting
cancer from that cheese for sure that's
what your choices are so I made a choice
to eat [__]
uh what flavor were they
lemon flavored sardines or some [__] it
was the yellow can
we used to just sit there at night with
[__] crackers you piss smells weird
your piss smells like [__] I would
piss it took me like six months to get
out of jail when I got out of prison for
my piss to change the smells oh because
there's got to be something that [__]
sardine there's got to be a lot of bad
[__] in that too yeah do you ever do you
ever like grab a can just for old time's
sake do you ever Miss sardines and
crackers I'm gonna be as honest with you
[__] as I can I remember
sitting in the joint and asking and
saying wow
I'm going to eat sardines the rest of my
[__] life I'm gonna be as honest with
you [__] I can't I haven't seen
a sardine since they let me out of that
[__] once I I'm like those born-again
Christians in jail once they get out
they throw the book up in the head
[__] that I I love sardines to the
minute I step foot on that [__] thing
I'm not even eating Caesar salad anymore
[__] them but the funny thing is that I
went somewhere to a [__] high level
restaurant a couple months ago I don't
know what restaurant it was they had
sardines on the menu I had an Italian
[__] heavy duty you know I used to
eat smelts right like in a can with oil
right why that's what you eat when
you're in jail right I don't know what
they probably had sardines they were a
little higher class yeah at the
restaurant I would hope it wasn't
canceled the [__] cancer beans you
can see that guy they got [__] male
pattern baldness already they're a
little fish they got no hair you know
they're [__] they're [__] nuts
those sardines
and then you know so yes I was my when I
was selling cars I was making money
right I didn't even use my kitchen I was
25 and single I'm not going to use my
kitchen so I get it you're not going to
use your kitchen I'm not gonna go home
and make chicken cacciatore after a
12-hour [__] day some people do
dogs some people do listen man anybody
this is a big thing it's so weird that
people haven't put this together
when you see these Hollywood celebrities
and they're like I worked out today and
I ran at the gym and I did all this [__]
they had nothing else to do all day
right when women feel insecure because
they'd see Jennifer Lopez and they're
like why can't I look that way I'll tell
you why because you work in a [__]
office and you're sitting there and
Mildred
she brings cookies every [__] day you
know yeah and it's also you're not
getting millions of like if I would like
to think if I had a Marvel movie on the
line I could put down the cheeseburger
for a couple months but you never I mean
it's
it's also
just
at a certain point like what you were
saying earlier you crack like even if
people always tell you to meal prep
though I tried every meal delivery
service everyone that you cook yourself
that you just put in the microwave they
all sucked some of them yeah most of
them sucked most some of them are okay
but I don't know what I want to eat for
dinner tonight two weeks ago no so I
would let most of them I threw away
thousands of dollars because I didn't
know what I like I'm just not the person
and I could but like I couldn't have
chicken breast rice and broccoli every
every day for every meal it's I wish I I
wish I could but I'll just I'll lose
I'll go crazy that's wrong go crazy and
I'll just end up in a drive-through like
I'll just I'll kind of like I'll snap a
little bit
interesting man there's a thousand ways
to get healthy and they don't all
require meal prep we just get lazy we
have we have busy lifestyles
and we don't know listen I know 20
heavyweight people don't even know where
to start to lose weight
they don't know people don't they really
don't and I mean listen you do okay push
yourself away from the [__] table and
stop eating the Breyer's ice cream okay
at night that's that's the simple way
but for some people that seems Out Of
Reach and I was one of those people yeah
the Weight Watchers
and go this is going to work I was I
thought I was lying to myself yeah I
dude you told you were I'm gonna go to
Weight Watchers for years I went to the
last Weight Watchers meeting in La
before the pandemic I went and like the
next day everything closed and I was so
[__] happy because I wouldn't have to
go to work but find the way Watchers
meeting around here because I like those
meetings and I could see them being very
helpful I think
when I was that big the problem was like
it was like the only thing giving me
happiness I'm like so wait I'm I'm gonna
I'm gonna not eat it and then like for
what like at because when you were
saying people don't know what to do
people can make you like you can make a
mistake like the Italian ice like oh
this has two servings
I think everyone knows what to do you
just I don't want to have salad like
like last night at that place there were
40 things I would have had rather have
had than the Greek salad that I had like
now granted I had fried shrimp before
and we had we got so messed up I had
croissant french toast for dessert but
when I ordered what I ordered originally
I made a good choice but it's just you
don't want to in the moment you're just
like [__] it I want
steak I want a burger I don't and look
it's like sort of like working like when
you go from college to a job you're like
wait this is every day like it's like
the first week of a diet you're pretty
good usually you get motivated you lose
a little weight and then three months in
you're like you hit a plateau
and you're having cauliflower rice again
you're like
[__] it
I'm gonna I'm gonna gain it back anyways
let's just [__] enjoy it and then and
then you do that for a little bit and
then suddenly the pants you bought don't
fit anymore and you're depressed so
there's a happy medium in life yeah and
you can eat healthy for 10 days and then
one day have a [__] Carvel Shake and
you can't beat yourself up over it
because you're doing the work it's not
like I sit here every night like typical
America how they want you to do and just
eat a bag of chips every night if it was
up to us we'd eat a bag of chips every
night that's how we were with a pint of
ice cream yeah that's how we were raised
that's how you know it's my time of
buying ice cream whatever the [__] it is
but we're never raised to eat an apple
yeah you know these are little things I
I told my wife I go I was having a hard
time
picking up a piece of fruit in the
daytime
I just have a hard time I'll do it for
three days in a row then I won't do it
for a week it's just let's just cut the
fruit up in the mornings don't cut it an
hour before let's chop it up in the
morning before we eat breakfast and I
incorporate a bowl of fruit I've always
loved fruit for breakfast when I go to a
[__] place and they give you two eggs
and bacon and they give you that little
cup of petrified fruit I eat that better
better fried fruit first especially if
it's got like blueberries or raspberries
in it
but to get back to the other thing and
it is economic you know not it's not
listen go buy a steak today go get a
steak today are you going to be in shock
you're really going to be in shock
whether you go to Manalapan Diner
or whether you go to Char Steakhouse
you're going to be in shock by the
sticker you're going to Stakes are high
and so am I yeah you know what I'm
saying Joey's grocery store so steaks
are high everything eggs are high so
what does a family do they have to
resort to the Boston Market dinner deal
which ain't bad I've been there dog for
years I ate Boston Market turkey for
Thanksgiving yeah okay because for a guy
like me as a single guy with a
girlfriend I'm not gonna make it [__]
turkey
okay that and Boston Market turkey is
Turkey's turkey
's [__] turkey okay no calories high
in protein it puts you to sleep you know
but for me I don't know if Boston Market
is even considered fast food I don't
know I know the chicken is horrible if
they started using cancer chickens from
[__] Bolivia or something that's
where I'd go when I was tricking when I
was trying to trick myself thinking I
was eating healthier I think I'll go to
Boston Market but then the yeah the yeah
you're like the problem isn't the
chicken or the turkey
potatoes the yams with the right
marshmallows on top that cream that
creamy spinach absolutely but it's
there's ways to do it there's ways to do
it but it's
it's very tough even to be honest even
fast food is expensive now so like what
holy [__] yeah a couple weeks ago I got
up on a Saturday morning I got up a
little early
my wife was sleeping I said let me be a
good husband and go over to McDonald's
and just get three Egg McMuffins yeah
that's it Greg McMuffins ain't gonna
kill you did the points are low no it's
a real egg they crack it yeah it's like
12 points on there or some eight points
not that bad you don't eat the potato
pancake oh I do and I drink a little bit
of the orange juice four ounces nah you
know you're trying to you're trying
that's not the point of the story point
of the story was I got three breakfasts
two cinnamon rolls one for Mercy have
you had the cinnamon rolls from
McDonald's yes they're the best [__]
cinnamon rolls you've ever had in your
life they don't skimp on that white
cream yeah yeah we got a cinnamon roll
they always skimp on the white cream you
ever make them at home Pillsbury always
gives you that package that don't have
enough cream for all of them you're like
[__] oh they give you just
enough and [__] like this I I would be I
would become like a mathematician like I
would scoop just the same amount and
then I would drag it on the pan I would
I would take it like it was a chip with
dip and I would scoop the cup I but that
one McDonald's aren't bad yeah when
they're hot telling you if there's
everybody went down a drain like if you
go to any place in Jersey any
Supermarket you walk in has that little
tray with the cinnamon rolls or they got
the other muffins
and they're not bad but they're great
McDonald's
[__] whatever anyway how much was it
37 [__] you
for three egg sandwiches and two yeah no
I told him I showed my wife the receipt
where I was like dog
it's gonna be a cold winter gentlemen
ladies and gentlemen yeah I'm not
sitting here just dropping stupid [__]
I'm telling you that don't take much
that restaurant we went to last night
I got bad news for you that
motherfucker's packed seven days a week
yeah good stuff there's always going to
be people there there wasn't a lot of
people I mean it was people there were
people but it wasn't slammed that
[__] gay guy sang Happy Birthday five
happy birthday I hate that [__] we
were dying I even told the guy you like
the official Birthday singer because gay
people love birthdays I know it was
about gay men they have learned to feed
they boy like the white socks and they
float up and down and [__] this guy was
so happy every time because he came out
of the back like oh baby you ever see uh
the bird cage yeah I love that movie uh
Robin Williams what's the other dude
that the Spanish maid
yeah oh please please that's a great
movie you do you do not like my spot
what you do not like mice by those
willingness my heat it's like it's kid
what's his name is Kiara is that him
something yeah heck is area Hank is area
but that's what he would do he would
always when they were singing happy
birthday he's like happy birthday to you
with the gay boys [__] tremendous
that's a great movie Doug yeah bird cage
is [__] Gene Hackman to see Gene
Hackman The French Connection
chasing [__] black people getting hit
by cars and then to see him and [__]
dad
the red case oh my God
I love all that [__] but just to keep
this conversation on track to talk about
when I lived with Josh Wolf
highs 97 to 99. now after after I
started all the Taco Bell money after
after I started to talk about money the
shells the [__] sour cream after I
snorted everything I went into a deep
[__]
period we all were
from the end of
ninth beginning of 99 to
the end of 98 to 99 was rough that one
summer
I'll never forget 98 going into 99 was a
rough summer that's when I used to Rob
cigarettes from the gas station in the
morning
or put cigarettes on the arm I would
steal a pack and put it back on credit
and buy one get one free he just didn't
know and then I would go to Josh walks
and hopefully he had a turkey burger
or I would wake up around female and
hopefully he could give me five bucks
and I would walk to Wendy's
and get for five bucks in those days I
get the junior cheeseburger I get the
bowl of chili because that I I needed
the most bang for my [__] Buck I got
five dollars here man
I get the bowl of chili and the junior
cheeseburger and I'd [__] get like a
large iced tea and I'd just lurk around
the salad bar like they always had the
salad bar when it was yellow I remember
I remember oh my yellow Wendy's was a
great place and guys when I was eating
that [__] do you think I was thinking
about my health do you think I was
thinking about the carbohydrate value in
this [__] I was just looking to survive
yeah I'm doing comedy when I was on the
road early on I was eating Subway
sandwiches at least I wasn't eating the
turkey and all that [__] I was getting
veggie and cheese you know but I know
what it's like to have a veggie and
cheese for lunch
and have a veggie and cheese for dinner
in your car
that's part of doing comedy that this is
it you wanted it you got it okay you
wanted it you got it like AC DC said
It's a Long Way to the Top If you want
to rock and roll and this is [__]
part of it and so that was the thing I
went on and then I went to Florida when
my apartment got towed and things
changed after that and I never stepped
[__] footing Wendy's ever again I
don't blame you and then over the years
it's always been
unlike any other body man I'm an
American and every once in a while I
want to [__] Quarter Pounder oh yeah
every once in a while I want to call the
pounder and red band that [__]
told me that Quarter Pounders are the
only hamburger that McDonald's sells
that is really meat
deal you have to look this up
everything else is like meat byproducts
and [__] donkey Tails yeah they sell
it for a dollar four yeah like I can't
like but those
I'll eat the [__] out of some nuggets
all but yeah those quarters those
Quarter Pounders aren't bad like nuggets
are nasty yeah it's it's chicken hot
dogs that are fried
goo that they get formed into the Nugget
sheep but yeah Quarter Pounders listen
when you eat McDonald's you just it's
like eating White Castle you bite into
it you close your eyes and you say Enjoy
when I go to White Castle I don't eat 15
Burgers I eat three because that's what
I'm like conscious can live with right
three double burgers with steamed cheese
the fries and the [__] Pepsi with the
soda and I eat it and I don't look back
because I know I'm not gonna eat it
again tomorrow this is just a situation
that happened today I got you know we
moved here we went to White Castle two
times in three months asked me if I've
been there again no I asked my daughter
you want to go to White Castle
look at you I'm okay but you know these
are the things you do in economic yeah
when you're an economic dire situations
you know when I look at and I don't I'm
not here to judge or say anything wrong
with that but when I go into a store
that has a family dinner
I kind of like that place if you know
anything about me and my beef with the
American family so any place that I see
has like a family bargain like you know
Sundays yeah like any like notice
you feed the kids free on Sunday oh
perfect I'll go there every Sunday it's
it's my heart you know what I'm saying
you don't think you're going to know
this but for them to do that I support
owners from time to time because they do
that they I'm big on that if I go to all
night like Australia and Marlboro it
costs you eight dollars to walk in the
door that
okay it's gonna cost you eight dollars
you're gonna get the best food You're
Gonna it's gonna be fresh the lettuce is
fresh everything's fresh
but you're gonna spend eight dollars to
walk in is that the place where they
come around with the parmesan cheese to
put it on for you it's like it's already
grated and then just some guy with a
spoon yeah it's true that that it costs
you eight dollars to [__] but on the
Monday night when you do a 1695 Burger
which and if you go to the best burger
in Jersey and uh the stage it's 24 for
that burger and it's [__]
mind-boggling it's it's a [__] sexual
experience okay when you bite into the
cheeseburger at the stage it's a sexual
experience it's better than eating [__]
the first time you can sit there and
stare out into the sky what's so good
about it what do they do I I have no
idea I don't know what it's dog I've
been in there with gorillas that want a
steak and they'll still get a
cheeseburger the last time I went we got
six steaks and we got two cheeseburgers
chopped up God bless you four pieces
yeah just cut it each person the manager
came over it's like you guys look a
little confused what's going on we're
like man
we're in a steakhouse and all of us like
we're in a steakhouse we really want to
get a steak and a lobster tail but God
damn that [__] Burger's real it's the
number one Burger in New York City wow
and it's in Jersey and they took it off
the list after one four years in a row
like we can't how can the best Jersey in
New York being [__] Jersey that's
crazy but yeah those you called me when
I was in L.A I was at probably one of my
top happy hours that I know of sushi Dan
from like three to five I would I love
happy hours I don't when when you go in
and the rolls they're usually 12 but
they're six or something I went in there
and had like an 80 lunch but it was
because I [__] had I just didn't stop
I I'll a happy hour especially at a
sushi place where you sit at the at the
sushi bar and this guy starts giving you
ones you didn't order oh I love a happy
hour because that's because that that's
when you can really get your money's
worth that's when you're like [__] it
I'm gonna you know when I used to go to
San Jose with you right I loved original
joke oh yeah you [__] ran through
original that place was great you could
get a side of ravioli I've never even
had that before but but
before I hit all those restaurants I
always went to McCormick and Schmitz
I support McCormick and Schmitz to the
end because when we were starving Comics
those [__] had a two dollar
menu and they never turned me away I
will never forget that
if I see a McCormick and Schmitz if I go
to anywhere Toledo Kentucky Wherever I
Go when they go go down there there's a
bunch of restaurants you'll like you'll
see a California you know what's the
California Pizza Kitchen yeah California
Pizza no but what's the other one the
Cheesecake Factory okay yeah when you
like when you go to Columbus Ohio and
you stay at the hotel just walk you're
gonna hit all of them Every Chain you
want you know whatever from uh the
steakhouse to [__] the little ones
but if I see a McCormick and Schmitz
they all go out the window I go support
them first because when me Josh Wolf
Brody we were broke [__] comics and
I'm talking about
guys you know when you're like looking
at a bag of chips going I hope this
thing has protein in it when you're at
the comedy club and you're like I hope
they make a mistake with the kitchen
that type of hunger we would go to
McCormick and Schmitz and they had a two
dollar [__] menu and I would
if we had fifty dollars think of the
damage you could do on a two dollar menu
the two dollar menu was from four to
seven and from ten to close and you'd be
there what 1001 we'd get here right
after the show we get there at 11 15.
maybe and stay till two it was two
dollars for a bottle of coke okay you
know those really good 16 ounce ones
yeah we would get those it was two
dollars for another french fries nice
two dollars for a [__] quarter pound
cheeseburger they had like shrimp
cocktail for two bucks for Katrina
shrimp you know you don't care at that
point no no I don't care but my loyalty
always goes to them because of what they
did for me with that happy hour many
nights hey Like A Champion
because you don't put it together like
people are like well I'd rather go to
McDonald's
they're offering a two dollar menu
dickwad I just told you you get a
quarter of fries and a huge [__] uh
hamburger for four [__] bucks two
more for the soda that's six give her a
four dollar tip so next time you go in
there she'll throw you in order for
fries for free right because you threw a
two dollar trip most people who go to
the two dollar menu are dead beats they
don't tip that they'll leave chains like
pennies and a diamond [__] you know when
you give that you know the two dollar
menu you give a four out of your last
ten
and she's probably going God damn good
for you come in I'll throw you a soda
and that's what happened they would
throw us Cokes all the time you know
yeah that's and when you would you get
excited like you knew you got a show
that night you're like oh we'll go to
McCormick and Schmick that's the first
thing I think we used to go to Hollywood
what was what was our thing on Saturday
nights we always went and got a piece of
pizza yeah with Eric we did comedy but
then we just did our comedy let's go get
a slice of pizza and we Giggle and then
go home it was a simple [__] night
we'd go and I did the drive the last
time but we'd only stop if there was a
parking spot I would get pissed when
there was no parking spot because like
there wasn't always a parking spot there
but we didn't we'd stop oh and there was
just when you're going like that like
you were saying earlier about getting
something to go home like after a spot
to go and grab that slice and we'd get
to eat one there bring one home you have
that one waiting
there's nothing like setting up the
night with food when you're a fat [__]
these are things you do and listen
some people may go to McDonald's to get
prepared I'm not mad at you some people
might go to Taco Bell that's part of it
that's crazy that we have also had Taco
Bell on my block in L.A and that [__]
Taco Bell at night dog it would wrap
around the corner cars can keep them
[__] driving Magnolia oh it was open
all night yes and that's the only thing
it opened all night in L.A that's what
always you know when you go how many how
are these people eating this [__]
and you know ex people are still smoking
cigarettes after all the warnings yeah
you know so people gonna do what the
[__] they want last thing I want to talk
to you about real quick
um
not big just I just want to see what
your thoughts on that were okay
no offense either no for anybody who
watches it please give us a [__]
break uh
how do you feel being Jewish with all
this [__] going on the last [__]
three weeks two weeks so I'll preface
this by saying I avoid the new so I know
I know what he said vaguely but the
problem is like I'll hear are you I've
seen like the clips and then I was
talking to someone who's like really
into that world and he was saying well
he said it a different way
it's
it's definitely tough it's tough
like the death con thing I don't know
what you mean by that but that doesn't
seem good and then
the the part that's like scary is like
not even so much that he says it but
then I forget where it was I think it
was somewhere at like a sporting event
someone had a projector that was
projecting like Kanye was right about
the Jews someone in L in like LA or
somewhere had like a sign up on the
overpass that the Kanye was right about
the Jews it's uh
it's just people are so angry that like
you don't know
what people are gonna do and
it's
I get being frustrated and I get all
that because I don't know what's going
on in Kanye's life
but yeah it's all the [__] going around
it it can get scary because you don't
know
what's gonna set someone off if like if
you say something if you say someone
know finds out you're Jewish and they go
crazy it's uh
it's just a weird time but I I to be
honest I avoid it and it is
as much as like it's crazy what he said
and
it's crazy that like how quickly his
entire world Just Came Crashing Down
just like Adidas is gone he's getting
escorted out of Puma or wherever it was
you and he I saw on something that he's
on an interview he said like I didn't
break any laws and he didn't he didn't
break any laws but
in this day and age you can't you just
can't say [__] like that we had a
podcast we did I did a podcast with Mike
last week
and I spoke about that I didn't know the
impact that a person could have with
their voice yep
I never did you know and I've been
warned before as a child but be careful
what you say and [__] but I never looked
at it like that I thought Kanye's
remarks were like any other idiots
remarks in life they're going to be
dismissed I not being a Jewish person
but
liking having a lot of Jewish friends
some might considered family somebody
considered friends I looked at it and I
was like you know because the first
thing you read is Jamie Lee Curtis who
isn't Jewish broke into tears because
her father was Jewish then again people
forget Halloween's around the corner and
she's trying to sell tickets for a
[__] movie again how October's a
[__] month you know so she's got to
come up with something so I when I saw
that right away I go here come the
phonies right yeah there's a lot of that
I saw that you know he was around for a
week and the comments were out there and
then I saw that uh
CA had let him go I called one of my
agents and I go you let my boy go you
know like a joke
Joey we had to yeah they have no choice
because we had to not because listen I
at first he was off the meds you know
there's a thousand excuses I could make
for you and and and in time a blow over
people understand mental health as a you
know uh the kid from Comedy Central is
quitting the David yeah Trevor Noah said
the same thing I said I and I didn't
copy it from him I saw he said a day's
later I got no beef with mental health
right it's not just
it's not just him if you look at wide
along the Spectrum you're going to see a
lot of people that are slowly losing
their mind little by little entertainers
and Antonio Brown walked off a field
through his shirt I'm 59 years old I've
been watching football for years
nobody's ever quit in the middle of a
game throwing his shirt up in the
[__] air and done it I got a thousand
[__] theories yeah I'm not conspiracy
theories but I got a thousand legit
theories that I've you know I've watched
a lot of 60 Minutes I watched a lot of I
read a lot of stuff this this uh that
little break in life that we had
it affected people gave us too much time
to think right for some people for some
people they didn't think enough for some
people they got all this time to think
and once the World opened up they went
out there like a [__] racehorse and
they didn't deal with the [__] that they
had brought upon with the pandemic
there's a thousand excuses I can make
but the only excuse I can't make for
Kanye or anybody else because now
they're attacking the guy from the Nets
Tyree yeah I don't have no idea what he
said I did not see the he supported
something he put up a tweet of a movie
that made anti-semitic remarks you know
I saw the the [__] sign on the the
stadium Kanye was read about the Jews
and that's what got me [__] up when I
heard about the people hanging signs and
that they passed out flyers in Beverly
Hills you know those are old Jewish
people they don't [__] know right you
know they don't know what's going on so
yes they contacted CA or whatever I
don't know the story
and they got rid of them but now I what
I was really Blown Away by and I told
Mike and everybody else last week was
how
the response he got that he got a
negative response to the comments but
then he got he dug up these old [__]
Jew haters you know and [__] Nazis
yeah and that's when I saw the problem
and that's when I understood why people
were mad at Joe I wasn't mad at Joe for
what he was saying got nothing to do
with me but I understand the power of a
voice now I understand why they're so by
Gentiles are so mad at Trump for saying
he incited to ride on the sex right
maybe he made a remark people took it
the wrong way look at when he's told
people to drink bleach [__]
drank bleach yeah that's that's the you
and I us three the Golden Triangle
between the three of us there's no
[__] vibrated campus here we didn't
drink the [__] day but he drank the
bleach so
and that goes to tell you where people's
head is at we're so lost as human beings
I don't know what Kanye did with it
Kanye is the king of uh uh attention oh
yeah those guys are the king of making
algorithms and whatever the [__] they
want to call you know I don't know if he
did this as a joke to blow he's not
blowing anything up yeah it's not like
he's it's not like two weeks from now
he's like did you know Kanye had an
album coming out and you're like no
wonder he made those remarks he's like
ah but we're just trying to sell them
out right but we're talking about him
and I don't know if you saw this I
something came across my Instagram it
was an interview with Elvis and someone
was asking him about would he sign up
for the war because he was he had
previously served and he was like hey
man I'm an I'm an artist I don't really
want to talk about that I don't have an
opinion and they said oh do you have an
opinion on other artists saying this
he's like no I don't have an opinion on
that either so it's I'm not saying
celebrities can't say their opinion but
people have always hated
from the beginning of time people have
hated Jews
that's never going to change
unfortunately people are going to hate
everybody
but if you're gonna if you're gonna have
those thoughts just keep it to yourself
like it's like I I think that's the
scariest part is is it just one piece
someone like that says it people around
the world feel like they can say it too
and it just it leads to bad [__] you
know when we started when we're doing
the church I was on the road a lot and
I'd make [__] crazy remarks on the
road on the podcast about African
Americans and make Hindus I'd make jokes
about [__] Puerto Ricans and I'd make
joke about all these other ethnic groups
and then I go to a show in that town
and boy would I want to take a picture
with me a guy from that ethnic group or
an African-American kid I went to New
Orleans I thought they were going to
kill me
because to add insult to injury I was
bombing and I did that stupid joke about
when I got fired
[__] calling the guy a moon cricket
and uh I was like I'm gonna get killed
at the end of this show
and at the end of the show the people
were talking to me the most were
African-Americans and African-American
chicks and whenever I go into a town
like when I would say the hummus jokes
and all that [__] Arabs will come to my
show and bring me hummus and we'll laugh
about it so my words even though I was
saying [__] to the untrained eye they'd
look and go that guy's making racist
remarks the people that I was making the
racist remarks about and not in a bad
way was a joke like you know you smell
like ten dead Puerto Ricans even Puerto
Ricans laugh at that they would come to
the show and go we heard that joke and I
would go holy [__] I didn't get beat up
I didn't get punched in the face by that
big error but I didn't get punched in
the face by the Indian family right they
like the joke they even come and
mentioned it to me well you were just
saying it you were just saying we don't
know what Kanye's intention was
and the people who would come to your
shows
know that you don't hate them
they know your intent was I'm
not anything but I think you would say
most anything if you thought it would
make people laugh if you thought if if
it didn't if it wasn't like horrible and
you thought it would make like an
audience laugh you'd probably say it
yeah
the the thing is is we're none of these
people know who Kanye is none of these
people who knew Kyrie Irving is or what
he really thinks and they hear it and
they're just they're just taking it for
what he actually said
you would say [__] that yeah like you my
favorite thing was going to TSA or to
eat with you late at night and there'd
be a woman there and you would say stuff
that would send people to to jail no no
not that but you would like hit on them
like very openly
and but like not and but they could even
tell like you weren't actually hitting
on them but you were complimenting them
but just in ways my favorite one was at
TSA because you would have me go with
you to like the first class line and I
was always [__] nervous but there
would be these African-American women
working at LAX at four in the morning
they were but they were already happy to
be there they were already full of
energy and you'd you all walked up to
one and I think it's a line you've used
before but you would say I'm gonna tear
the Beyonce poster off the wall and then
it would [__] lose it they would love
oh my God I would
if I thought of saying that to anyone I
thought I thought I'd get smacked and
you walked up and you would like be like
tremendous you just walk away you
wouldn't even wait for them to respond
she was a hot sister guy she had to be
about 50.
probably five eleven two eighty with
blonde streaks in the head just a sister
looking [__] beautiful in the morning
and other people are looking like oh
she's just a big woman I'm telling you
this chick was beautiful yeah and we
became friends and every time I wouldn't
have to show him my card I just go look
at you sexy [__] and she go oh
my God
but I would do that to have I didn't
care because I'm not hitting on you I'm
just letting you know who doesn't want
to know at four in the morning if
they're a sexy [__] when you
tell a woman at four in the morning when
you bump up until 4 30 in the morning
she's feeling she's not even thinking
about looking good she's just thinking
about getting to the job and having a
kid's [__] lunch packed and she's
there waiting online and people like hi
do you know my fight's delayed hi you
know where to get my luggage and also I
come up to look as smooth as a
[__] today aren't you and that's
exactly what I'm saying you're looking
smoother than a [__] today and
while they're signing my thing and
looking at my idea like hmm
and the sisters of the basket you can
get away with that you're looking good
today if I had an extra 20 minutes I'd
take down a date don't they go off the
boat they go off the best was the time
we were at at the steakhouse
there was lady who had to be [__] 70
walked past us dolled up she looked like
a [__] antique but in her mind she
looked good in her mind she was out
dressed to impress and she came by the
table and I'm like you looking [__]
remember I said something to her oh yeah
I'm gonna pull the wig off or something
yeah and she [__] came back and gave
me her number oh yeah oh yeah we were
sitting right by the bathroom right
right by the bathroom oh God you should
call me once in a while
she was like 75. this is five years ago
four years ago over there longer than
that yeah yeah that was crazy the dog
just trying to make that day that's it
you should say when that me too thing
came out three years ago I was depressed
and I go you know what I'm not gonna
stop being me over it there's no way
there's no way I got these moms on my
block
the lady who shot me in the face five
times last week with the needle she
walked past my house every day oh I got
on the paint her and the Asian lady Jan
up the corner right my mom's on this
block okay I tell them more I got the
hottest all of them I tell them all you
guys I got the hottest moms of my
[__] block that's right they're like
Joe you're so silly
I I don't know how you do it but there's
the leader up there so I call her at a
house direct and like I just seen Dr
aliona and I seen Jen I got the hottest
moms on the blocks and she'll call them
and go Joey just said that about it
they'll go oh my God he said it to me
too he's so sweet I didn't even do my
hair this morning you know [__] like
that they walk around here yeah all they
robbing from up the corner they all walk
here and I tell Robin every day Robin
and she'll look up looking good and
she'll just walk away shaking her head
like this [__] he knows my
husband he knows I'm goofing him I love
all that [__] yeah and they love it and
you may and that's what like you said me
too like you never you don't touch them
you don't make them uncommon like you
literally say it and walk away sometimes
and like they they'll just they just
it makes them it's I don't know if it's
a compliment or what it is it's a
[__] crazy it's letting somebody know
that look that listen man there's
nothing a woman wants more
for a man to say that you look very nice
today I like your shoes I like your hair
if you do that with your mom you're a
[__] winner you know if you do that
with your girlfriend or your wife
because they don't expect it anymore
right your wife doesn't expect you to go
I like that blouse so if you say it once
in a while like that blob I like your
hair it makes that day and that's where
we're in the business of doing
absolutely just making somebody's day
with a simple hello anything what's
going on you fat [__] anything that
nobody else says to them
I think I went for a milkshake the other
day no and he put THC in it oh you did
it okay yes if you use the T8 season
that's some THC you want me to put it in
I go put it all in there well you're
like you got an ice cream man that comes
by the house that's oh yeah that has a
soft day till Friday tomorrow is this
Friday is his last day I'll be here
until the winter comes about three
[__] 30 feet my daughter will walk in
at three and go Mr Salty's coming today
how do you know he told me last week
yesterday I'm like I don't think he's
coming because it was cloudy I don't
think he's coming [__] it
showed up I'm like Mercy she was already
outside
I love it she was already outside it's
just uh it was just disturbing and I
wanted to see I'm not Jewish I don't
really hang out with a lot of Jewish
people here
you're basically my only Jewish friend
we talk on the phone but I wanted to
check with you to see if you had spoken
I don't know if you go to Temple still I
don't my my family's upset there are a
lot of people who are very upset and I
get it especially like my parents
generation because like their parents
were like in the Holocaust and or like
their grandparents maybe
um
and I I understand being upset I'm I
apologize just because I
living with my parents the past couple
years
it just show has shown me like how much
because they they always watch the news
so I've just made a concerted effort to
be like I just can't I watch a little
bit of the local news I read what I'm
interested in but I see the Kanye stuff
and I don't even watch it I don't want
to see some so much I think now they're
just making stuff up because he won't
shut the [__] up every day I I just stop
I just I'm really uh
it's so funny the last six months or so
I really been trying to tape them down
my time every Sunday I get like a little
message that says this week you spent
you know how many hours I can't look at
that I'm trying to get no I got it down
under seven a whole week yeah I got sick
and tired of being on there for 10 hours
you know I can't imagine what I was on
there when we lived in L.A and I finally
a couple months ago I was like I kept
seeing that thing coming up screen time
I'm you know what this isn't healthy
because eight hours you're losing a day
on the computer yeah that's a work day
you're doing on a computer and what are
you doing looking at people on Twitter
you know and there's times listen the
other side of that is there's times I
put YouTube on
just when I'm doing [__] right and
Facebook and Twitter will be open and
people think I'm on them I'm not on
there at all it's so funny I'll go on
Facebook and I get no messages and once
I leave the thing open with YouTube
playing I come back and I got eight
messages I guess it tells you when
somebody's up yeah yeah I don't I don't
even know where the [__] to start that
so it's kind of weird when that happens
but no I just wanted to see where it was
at like I said people gonna say [__] all
the time
but I think right now we're just in a
mental health
I'm saying it I felt it for a little
while I felt my actions
and then I got a little [__] you know
I started journaling again just to get
my feet back under me listen I'm still
crazy but I'm not saying Jew jokes on
[__] CNN you know what I'm saying I'm
not right I'm not you know saying [__]
about Jews or any other group on CNN but
it's not just I noticed it with Erza
Miller was crazy for a while that he
must have yeah he must have drank some
[__] [__] juices Jesus on a full
moon you know uh
yeah because they had to sit him down
and talk to him and go enough is enough
you can't drink [__] juice on a
midnight on a full moon
you know that's what happens you can't
you can drink the [__] juice not on a
full moon
Jesus
no no it's it's out there and it's and
we're seeing look at bro till this day
nobody has mentioned Antonio Brown is
what stealing watches and throwing
t-shirts and I mean with him it could be
the CTE but he was around donda for a
while too he was hanging around with
that [__] dude too I love that he's
posting pictures of giselda I think
that's hysterical I mean he's losing his
mind yeah he's losing his mind and
listen there's a lot of people you know
I think Kyrie Irving's been [__] for
years you know I really do think he's
[__] for [__] years this just put
I don't even you know I love him as a
basketball player yeah if you bet him to
score 28 points tonight he'll cover he's
he always covers with a bet but that
[__] dog listen man it's just a
different world and
this is the only place where we find a
little bit of [__] peace doing a
podcast once in a while I hope I don't
come on here and say [__] crazy [__]
about different
ethnic groups but even if you do
everyone knows what it means and it's
any it you can tell when people say it
with hate in their heart oh always
always and I don't have guys it's
the only thing you hate is Branch that's
all red stretch dressing that's it and
[__] who ask too many questions
the world's in a rough [__] place
right now but you know what we're headed
to the city tonight Cox up because I
love you thank you for watching The
Joint today I want to thank Lee and Mike
for being here and I'll see you
[__] uh next Monday tip top Magoo
I don't know about the rest of the week
because I'm shooting a movie so
congratulations now for a word for my
[__] sponsors Jack all right
you [__] thank you very much for
watching the podcast today or listening
whatever you chose I want to thank Lee
and Mike for being here and I want to
thank you guys for always being Savages
but I want to thank stamps.com they're
going to get you a holiday mailing and
shipping under control this year because
it's about to break loose you know what
it's gonna carrying boxes standing on
lines
bringing back stuff you don't need the
aggravation with stamps.com you print
postage wherever you do business all you
need is a computer and a printer that's
it with stamps.com you can easily
schedule pickup and compare carriers and
weights rates with the click of a button
and if you're running on an online store
stamps.com Works seamlessly with all the
major shopping carts and marketplaces so
do me a favor this holiday season you're
going to be busy enough
go to stamps.com today sign up with
promo code Joey j-o-e-y for a special
offer that includes a four-week trial
free postage and a free digital scale
you can't lose no long-term commitments
or contracts just go to stamps.com Click
the microphone at the top of the page
and enter code Joey it's that simple
stamps.com the best the joint is also
you're brought to you by CBD lion listen
there's a lot of facts and [__]
stories about CBD why mess around just
go straight to the source CBD lion the
best whether it's the vapor pens whether
it's the kinesiology tape whether it's
the cream whether it's the back balls
CBD lion is number one in that field and
I've tried them all CBD line is
consistent and they make the best
products available to you do do yourself
a favor go to CBD line read the third
party lab results and then get back to
me [__] it's gonna blow your [__]
brains out we got some tremendous stuff
and don't forget the Delta a gummies
you'll be hearing Chinese music like I
was but it starts with you go to CBD
line pressing code Joey joint what
church and I'm getting you 20 off it's
that simple I want to thank CBD lion I
want to thank stamps.com I want to thank
better help and I want to thank you guys
for always having my back have a great
week stay black and we'll see you
[__] Monday morning Tip Top
magooie
foreign
[Music]